here to respond dana lash nationally
syndicated radio show host and second
amendment rights advocate terrible
terrible closing arguments by the
prosecution one of the most alarming
things i've ever seen dana when the
prosecutor binge this slug actually
holds the ar-15 up
finger on the trigger and then just
points it
at the jury after the alec baldwin
situation could you believe
he would point a gun at the jury like
that
after some of the arguments jesse that
i've heard from what i'm calling brennan
and dale of the step brothers law firm i
i mean i believe it i mean it kind of
it's insane i mean he flags the entire
courtroom in jury and to be honest i'm
actually kind of surprised that a
bailiff or i don't know if they had a
state trooper in the courtroom didn't
intervene at that moment finger on the
triggers didn't even have it shouldered
properly he went to the alec baldwin
school of firearms handling apparently
but to that point there was something
else jesse in the closing arguments that
were interesting to me uh kraus or aka
dale doback i was listening to him say
oh no there's no such thing as right or
left-handed firearms well actually yeah
there is and i was really shocked to
hear a prosecutor say that in a
courtroom setting as though it had any
kind of factual weight i mean anyone
who's ever shot if you're right-handed
you shot with maybe a left-handed
shotgun or vice versa you know how your
weapons control or how brass is spent
that was that was also insane to me but
this is self-defense on trial and you
have a clown show of a trial that should
not even progress to this point because
i a thousand percent agree with you
jesse and i thought you made some
phenomenal points uh earlier on the five
this was a clear-cut case of
self-defense end of story and so the
state is trying to plant the seed of
reasonable doubt that's all they're
trying to do is just make it look like
he was somehow reckless well he
demonstrated better firearms discipline
than either of those two clown shows in
the courtroom today yeah so you have a
30 year old convicted felon
rapist of boys charging you at full
speed after gunshots have just been
heard he's threatened your life he
screamed at you and he lunges for your
weapon that's just one and then you have
another guy hitting you in the head with
a skateboard
your trip you're falling down on the
ground some other guy kicks you in the
face
and another guy points a loaded glock at
your skull
and i i honestly watched this video in
slow motion today you're looking at it
right here on the screen
in a sense
kyle showed amazing self-restraint in
that situation
and
that should be applauded
um but they want to make this guy out to
be an active shooter dana that's what
was the big line
this afternoon active shooter
which yeah that's such a that's actually
incredibly offensive as it's a
diminishment of mass casualty incidents
and there's a huge difference between
someone who's obviously going out to to
to carry out a mass casualty incident
and someone who's forced to defend
himself and doesn't even actually bear
and present his firearm in that manner
until he's knocked to the ground the
video is completely clear and the
discernment that he showed when gage
gross gross quits was approaching with
his glock extended you know in some
states low ready and then full
presentation you're talking about the
difference between a misdemeanor and a
felony and and i thought written house i
mean he realized when the threat was
advancing when the threat wasn't
advancing and then when groskowitz chose
to as we like to you know fafo and go
after somebody that was on the ground
and who was also armed and had better
training i mean look everyone talks
about jesse kyle being out there with a
firearm but what about the grown men who
were carrying illegally one of which was
a prohibited possessor what about these
guys who were out there armed and just
brandishing firearms and hunting down
people as they were burning down black
owned businesses which is another quick
point jesse everyone talks about race
but all i saw was a white convicted
pedophile who got out of a mental
institution decided to go to a riot and
help burn down black owned businesses
another white domestic abuser's charges
included strangulation and kidnapping
and another white criminal who was
illegally carrying a firearm white white
and white all with antifa burning down
black owned businesses so people want to
have a discussion about race there you
go it's really well said dana and that's
how the press is going to prime this
thing they're already priming it for
riots and that's why they have the
national guard out there as you as we
said at the top the jury's going to
start deliberating first thing tomorrow
morning right but i mean if you have a
white guy that shot two white guys
uh one a third white guy was wounded uh
in an all-white city with a with a
democrat governor democrat mayor
democrat d.a the press is going to want
to make this about race and as you saw
today they checked this kid's phone
this kid's 17 nothing about race nothing
about militia nothing about white
supremacy
there's nothing there exactly
nothing there at all whatsoever and
they're inc they are absolutely
incorrectly making this about race when
really it's about self-defense on trial
and one more quick point if i made jesse
when the when the prosecutor when the
state was arguing and they're closing
arguments and they were they they
actually said that because rosenbaum i
guess didn't bring a firearm to a fight
it was unfair for him well you don't go
around looking for trouble and you don't
have to meet that consequence but here's
the thing he said why couldn't kyle
rittenhouse just fight him with this
fist let's keep in mind that the exact
type of rifle that kyle rittenhouse was
carrying that evening is actually the
right the firearm that is involved in
the most or the least rather the least
homicides fbi uh crime reports ucr's
that you can find 2015 to 2019 that's
the last year available shows that hand
feet and fists are double the amount
used in homicides and homicide cases
then long rifles like kyle written
houses so i thought that was an
interesting point that the prosecutor
just inadvertently accidentally walked
into just another one of those
narratives that are just blowing up in
their face dana lash thank you so much
for joining us on prime time always good
to see